allez allez c'est l'heure de dévoiler
notre baromètre mensuel odoxa Public
Sénat la presse régionale Audrey comme
tous les mois on commence par la côte de
popularité de l'exécutif avec une
différence notable entre la côte du chef
de l'État qui se porte plutôt bien 35 %
des sondés estim qu'Emmanuel Macron est
un bon Président de la République c'est
un point de plus par rapport au mois
dernier où il avait déjà glané deux
points de popularité l'automne est donc
clément pour le chef de l'État notamment
en raison du contexte international je
pense qu'on y reviendra c'est pas le cas
de sa première ministre elabeth borne
toujours en difficulté dans l'opinion 69
% des Français estiment qu'elle n'est
pas une bonne première ministre ça n'a
pas changé depuis le mois dernier Orian
ouais on va en reparler longuement
d'Élisabeth B sur Emmanuel Macron heran
il regagne petit à petit des points de
popularité on en parle un peu chaque
mois qu'est-ce qui explique ça c'est le
contexte international ou c'est autre
chose oui c'est vrai il a des
respirations internationale pour sa côte
de popularité que n'a pas Elisabeth
borne ce qu' ce qu'on observe c'est que
on est sur une lente remonté de sa code
de popularité information aussi son
absence à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme ne semble pas lui porter
préjudice en terme de popularité pour
autant 35 % ça reste un niveau bas on va
voir tout à l'heure notre palmarès de
l'adhésion politique aujourd'hui il y a
deux chefs de parti Édouard Philippe
mais aussi Marine Le Pen qui ont des
codes d'adhésion supérieurs à à à ce
niveau-là et c'est ça ça pe ça pose
peut-être la nécessité pour Emmanuel
Macron de trouver une nouvelle dynamique
et aussi de reprendre de la hauteur par
rapport à la classe politique à plus
haut niveau d'adhésion alors que dans 6
mois il y a une échéance importante qui
arrive les Français retournent aux urnes
pour la première fois depuis la séquence
de la présidentielle et des législatives
il faudrait pas non plus que ce scrutin
européen se transforme en vote sanction
contre le gouvernement ou il y a un
risque cl c'est c'est ce que cherche à
faire notamment Marine Le Pen à en faire
un scrutin demiandat un vote sanction
contre Emmanuel Macron C Europ là on a
une séquence effectivement on sait que
c'était une des bornes excusez-moi pour
éventuel remanuniment notamment à la
tête du du gouvernement se dire on tient
jusqu'aux EUR européne dans le dans la
la chronologie du quinena c'éit un point
très important et c'est vrai que la
séquence la séquence internationale qui
qui est arrivée et qui est venue percuté
hein la vie nationale avec en plus un
attentat voilà a un peu mis en suspens
cette séquence on voit qu'Emmanuel
Macron parle des faits drapeau je sais
pas si on peut parler à ce point-là mais
c'est vrai que son attitude un peu voilà
en même temps sur sur pend toute cette
séquence et son absence à la marche
contre l'antisémitisme ne lui a pas
porté préjudice les Français ont plutôt
apprécié la façon dont elle dont il a G
cette situation mais c'est vrai que
Marine Le Pen on en reparlera elle tirer
son épingle du jeu de façon bien plus
importante donc quelque part même si il
fait de son de son mandat comment dire
de sa mission de rendre la France
sereine on voit bien que ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas encore arrivé et qu'à
l'approche de cette élection bah les
parties les plus contestataire en tout
cas le Pr national RN pardon attire son
épingle du jeuou et quand on regarde par
rapport aux proximité partisane puisque
c'est aussi ce que vous faites dans ce
baromètre heran Emmanuel Macron il gagne
7 points de popularité à la France
insoumise 8 points chez les républiqu
mais alors à la France insoumise ça
demeure à un niveau très bas donc on est
vraiment sur un genre d'effet drapeau
c'est-à-dire une certaine bienveillance
des citoyens à l'égard des responsables
politiques dans un contexte des mois
national et surtout queil y a eu des
attentats il y a eu un événement sur le
sol français qui a particulièrement
marqué l'opinion et à l'extérieur donc
pour pour cette remontée au sein des
sympathisants de la la France insoumise
on est sur de de la marge et plutôt un
effet drapeau chez les sympathisants LR
ça confirme l'ancrage à droite de la
majorité présidentielle et le fait que
la politique qui est menée par
l'exécutif convient au aux sympathisants
de la droite c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
soutien électoral qui penche de plus en
plus vers la droite et qui donne
satisfaction à ces sympathisants ouais
c'est pas surprenant cette remontée de
popularité d'Emmanuel Macron chez leslr
notamment dans le contexte de la loi
immigration on va en parler tout à
l'heure oui oui tout à fait j'avoue que
je enfin je parle t contrôle mais c'est
vrai que on voit des difficultés énormes
de l'exécutif aujourd'hui sur un de ses
principaux projets
les prochains mois qui le projet de loi
immigration on voit Gérald armanin
ministre de l'Intérieur qui a la
manœuvre justement bah au Sénat on l'a
vu pour essayer à tout prix d'éviter un
493 d'arriver à trouver d'élargir cette
majorité qui qui peinene à trouver en
fait depuis les législatives he sur ce
texte là et on a quand même vu que
l'absence d'ercotti très remarqué au
dernière rencontre de saint-enis ce
boycotte un peu surprise de cette
réunion de tous les chefs politiques
alors même qu'un accord de circonstances
semblaitêtre trouvé sur ce texte clé
montre qu'il y a quand même il y a un
véritable casse-tête en fait de la
majorité par rapport à LR un
positionnement très compliqué est-ce
qu'on on s'ancre définitivement de ce
côté-là quitte à laisser tomber la la
jambe gauche de cette majorité où on
voit bien que dans le texte sur
l'immigration il y avait quelques
mesures qui étaient
censé rendre de la cohésion à ce groupe
qui est un peu qui navigue à vue donc
c'est surprenant et pas voilà c'est que
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de de
prises de position qui vont de plus en
plus chercher dans le le discours du des
alr on voit bien que les alr sont
désorientés aussi et cherchent à se
démarquer du du mouvement majoritaire en
disant non non ils vont il faut pas
qu'on se fusionne et il est divisé lui
aussi donc je pense que c'est assez
voilà en tout cas symptomatique de du
flou qu'il y a aujourd'hui dans les dans
lesé clivage politique sachant que sur
l'immigration le projet fait beaucoup
moins débat dans l'opinion nationale que
dans la classe politique les Français
sont très majoritairement favoraable au
projet de loi immigration et à tous les
toutes les mesures qui qui contienent
donc c'est ça va plutôt dans le sens de
cautionner ce positionnement plutôt à
droite alors plutôt fermeté on dirait
dans la la base du projet de deemmanuel
Macron et la majorité on va parler
d'Élisabeth B puisque c'est elle qui est
au cœur de ce baromètre ce mois-ci alors
audre vous l'avez dit seul 30 % des
Français estim qu'elle est une bonne
première ministre il y a un autre
chiffre douloureux pour ellisabeth B oui
à la question Emmanuel Macron doit--il
changer de Premier ministre 61 %
descendés répondent oui une large
majorité qui se divise cependant sur la
personne pour la remplacer le mieux
placé je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est Gabriel hatal le ministre de
l'Éducation 30 % des Français pensent
qu'il ferait
le meilleur premier ministre devant
Bruno Le Maire 27 % et géralde d'armanin
10 points derrière alors une majorité
des sondés ne la voit plus à Matignon
vous nous l'avez dit il la voit pas non
plus du côté Strasbourg Bruxelles et non
et vous le savez le 9 juin prochain ce
sont les élections européennes la
majorité présidentielle n'a pas encore
annoncé sa tête de liste qui nous permet
de faire des suppositions mais pour les
Français ellisabeth borne tête de liste
Renaissance c'est une fin de non
recevoir ils ne sont que 28 petits pour
à soutenir cette idée Erwan qu'est-ce
qui explique ces chiffres notamment le
ce 61 % des Français qui ne sont pas
pour le maintien d'Élisabeth borne à
Matignon c'est quoi elle est elle est
trop techno c'est le fusible d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est c'est probablement le poids
de la réforme des des retraites aussi
dans une grande mesure on voit que sa
côe de popularité aussi entre 28 et 31 %
depuis le mois de janvier c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'y a eu aucun rebond post réforme
des retraites ce qu'a connu Emmanuel
Macron avec une séquence qui a été
doublement douloureuse pour elle sur la
forme où elle a été jugée maltraitante
ou méconnaissante des difficultés
sociales des travailleurs et sur sur le
fond sur sur la forme où le l'article
493 ça a été vécu pour l'adoption comme
un passage en force démocratique donc
son image ne se décolle pas de de ces
points néanmoins ce qu'on observe c'est
que les sympathisants Renaissance ne la
lâchent pas pour autant 86 % d'entre eux
jugent toujours que c'est une bonne
première ministre et ce sont les seules
hein elle elle bénéficie pas du soutien
des sympathisants
LR une 50 % mais ils sont aussi
majoritaires à souhaiter un changement
de Premier ministre et finalement ce ce
souhait de changement important ce
serait pas quelque chose de grave si la
majorité était absolue pour la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée nationale
mais dans une situation de majorité
relative que seul les sympathisants
Renaissance soutiennent ce premier
ministre en place ça indique qu'il y a
peut-être une volonté des des Français
d'élargissement de la majorité
gouvernementale et peut-être avec un
changement de Premier ministre sur la
question question des des européennes
quand on regarde les résultats alors 28
% uniquement des Français jugent qu'elle
ferait une bonne tête de liste mais 61 %
des sympathisant Renaissance donc ça
veut dire que il lui témoigne toujours
d'un certain soutien c'est ça pourrait
être une solution pour Renaissance qui
est quand même en grande difficulté dans
les intentions de vote aujourd'hui pour
rappel en 2019 le RN arrive en tête
finalement à 23 % devant Renaissance à
22 % aujourd'hui il y a 10 points
d'écart dans les derniers sondages entre
la liste Renaissance et la liste du du
Ren qui est largement en tête il y a
peut-être aussi la nécessité de mettre
un poids lourd pour conduire la liste
renaissance pour rattraper un pe retard
et faire en sorte que cette élection ne
s'apparente pas un vote sanction après
la séquence des élections
présidentielles législatives mais soit
une une réussite ou du moins minimise la
casse pour Renaissance clair sur ces
chiffres difficiles pour ellisabeth
borne oui tout à fait alors Elisabeth
borne est sans appel démenti toute
ambition européenne on a eu la chance de
enfin les lecteurs des dernières
nouvelles ont eu la chance de l'
interviewé la semaine dernière au
Parlement européen la question a été
posée a dit ce n'est pas mon projet je
doute pas qu'on aura une bonne tête de
liste pour mener en revanche notre
projet auquel on croit beaucoup elle
nous a énormément parlé d'Europe de
démocratie enfin voilà elle s'est posé
vraiment comme chef de gouvernement et
de majorité avec une volonté de de
conduire un projet bien différent de
celui du rassemblement national mais pas
en tant que que tête de liste juste
pardon claire là-dessus est-ce que le
fait que cette rumeur est courue sur le
fait qu'elle serait une tête de liste
pour Renaissance c'était une volonté de
ces détracteur de lui faire comprendre
qu'il fallait partir de matigon c'est
bien possible on a parlé de de baiser de
la mort en tout cas ses meilleurs
ennemis qui le lui souhaitaent c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment dans la macronie
l'idée d'un remanimement non pas après
les RX européennes et les j mais dès le
début de l'année voilà circule donc
voilà on sent bien que que le vent est
est plutôt mauvais c'est vrai que son
maintien à la tête du gouvernement en
juillet était un peu un choix par défaut
puisque comme vous l'avez dit il y a pas
de de majorité absolue l'idée circulait
évidemment que c'était le le fusible C
c'était dit il va y avoir une séquence
budgétaire très difficile il va falloir
de nouveau utiliser le 493 là dimanche
je crois que c'était le 19e cours au 493
elle a même on a même eu recours au 493
en l'absence de la première ministre qui
ce qui était pas arrivé depuis fort
longtemps quand elle était en Irlande
enfin c'est devenu une petite routine
qui pèse vraiment sur les débats chaque
fois il y a une motion de censure qui
est déposée enfin on rentre dans un dans
un système qui forcément doit doit
pénaliser euh la chef du gouvernement
dans un contexte où c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas de nouvel élan on sent pas de de
souffle dans cette on la voit à la
manœuvre he on a eu toute une séquence
donc il y a eu cette interview là à la
presse régionale avec ses électeurs on
la voyait à la manœuvre politiquement
elle voulait montrer que elle a annoncé
un plan pour les pour les violences
enfin contre les violences sur les
enfants les violences sexuelles et
sexistes on l'a vu hier sur le plan
biodiversité enfin on sent qu'elle veut
qu'elle veut émerger reprendre la main
au-delà de voilà de cette séquence
budgétaire qui est vraiment très
difficile mais va-t-elle voilà tenir
au-delà en tout cas l'air du temps ne
semble pas voilà dire que elle va elle
va porter le projet au-delà de de cette
séquence ouais et alors pour la
remplacer puisque vous avez posé la
question arait le rappeler les Français
mettent en tête c'est un peu la nouvelle
star de la macronie Gabriel hatal voilà
Gabriel Attal 30 % des Français disent
que ce serait le le meilleur ministre
pour la meilleur premier ministre pour
la succession d'Élisabeth borne devant
Bruno leemire 27 % alors que les autres
challengers ou prétendants sont
distancés ça c'est un point important
Gérald daranin arrive à un niveau plus
bas il a une image plus clivée ce qui
est assez classique des ministres de de
l'intérieur mais en tout cas
l'information principale c'est vraiment
que Gabriel fort de sa remontée dans sa
progression dans l'opinion depuis la
rentrée situe au même niveau que Bruno
Lemer voire même légèrement devant parmi
les premiers ministrbles ça c'est
l'information numéro 1 ensuite quand on
regarde les résultats un peu dans le
détail ce qu'on observe c'est que Bruno
Le Maire il y a quand même un poids de
son expérience politique dans l'opinion
chez les sympathisants Renaissance Bruno
Le Maire et juste devant Gabriel Attal
chez les sympathisants LR dont on a dit
tout à l'heure qui composait aussi les
soutiens à la majorité présidentielle
Bruno le est aussi devant et en fait il
est en tête chez tout le monde sauf chez
les écolos et le RN où là c'est Gabriel
Atal voilà alors le RN ça compte assez
peu parce que c'est pas eux qui
constitueront les soutiens à la majorité
présidentielle mais le centre gauche
c'est vrai soutient plus fortement
Gabriel Attal et on a un effetage aussi
très important la domination de Gabriel
Atal est très nette chez les moins de 35
ans celle de Bruno lEM est beaucoup plus
nette chez les 65 ans et plus qui sont
aussi une des composantes importante des
soutiens électoraux du de la macronie
donc il y a un match àal le maire à le
c'est V qu'à un moment on parlait plus
d'atal nanin on voit que c'est vrai que
la personnalité trèsclivante de Gérald
daranin a la distancé un petit peu dans
le et c'est vrai que Gabriel Attal on
pensait être un peu une bulle en tout
cas au début de cette rentrée
fracassante qu'il avait faite avec
énormément d'annonce bah se maintient en
fait dans dans l'opinion il a agi
beaucoup sur le harcèlement qui a été un
gros sujet là il s'est positionné sur le
le redoublement il devrait y avoir des
annonces qui est un sujet voilà la
baisse du niveau scolaire qui qui parle
beaucoup au français on l'a vu aussi
faire un peu le match avec Gérald
Darmanin après après l'attentat d'aras
où il a évoqué la possibilité de sortir
de l'école des élèves radicalisés donc
on voyait que ce souci de protection des
Français enfin il se positionnait un peu
de façon différente he du du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui lui était plus sur
l'immigration voilà donc c'est ça il se
il se positionne et Bruno LEM bah
effectivement j'ai l'impression que il
progresse alors je parle s le contrôle
d'an mais c'est vrai que bah on a une
séquence budgétaire un débat sur la
dette il y a pas mal de de
problématiques qui qui qui concernent
quand même pas mal les l'opinion
publique les Français il peut arriver à
avoir cette cette stature après est-il
suffisamment politique voilà ou en tout
cas proche des gens moi je je je
m'interroge voilà après c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on attend d'un Premier
ministre mais dans dans une suite voilà
politique il est peut-être moins incarné
quoi dans juste ouais dans dans la
méthodologie Erwan pour qu'on comprenne
bien est-ce que c'est vous qui avez
suggéré les noms de Gabriel at de de
donc ce sont des personnes qui
appartiennent à la majorité
présidentielle voilà absolument ou euh
on on va parler peut-être un mot du du
3e euh c'est Gérald armanin euh Gérald
armanin qui n'arrive que 3e 18 % ça veut
dire qu'il est pas porté par la loi
immigration qui pourtant vous l'avez
rappelé arwan est soutenu par une
majorité des français si alors il est il
est potentiellement porté par cette loi
mais auprès des sympathisants
probablement LR ou rassemblement
national qui sont plutôt les plus
favorables et les plus sensible à ces
questions d'immigration par contre à la
différence de Gabriel hatal et même de
Bruno Lemire qui ont des côte d'adhésion
plus transversale Gérald haranin il a
une côte d'adhésion qui quelque part
restaure beaucoup le clivage
gauche-doite on retrouve un peu ses
origin LR et du coup il a moins de 20 %
de code d'adhésion auprès des
sympathisants de l'anupes qui tire
nécessairement son soutien vers le bas
quand on fait la moyenne ouais
politiquement cette loi immigration
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose
pour Gérald haranin clair alors il
montre sa méthode qui est quand même
très différente de celle d'Élisabeth
borne parce qu'il y a aussi un match il
faut savoir depuis voilà où il n'a pas
caché son ambition d'être d'être Premier
ministre et bon il a pas eu gain de
cause on l'a vu à tourcoin voilà se
poser avec un entourage transpartisan qu
puis qu'il a quand même ramené des gens
de de de plusieurs horizons aujourd'hui
il montre que voilà on peut par
l'influence en ayant vraiment une
politique un peu plus politicienne arver
à un compromis donc il essaie je pense
qu' il émerge en tout cas s'il y arrive
parce que c'est un c'est un vrai
cass-etête on sait pas ce qui peut se
passer à l'Assemblée dans les prochains
jours le texte est en commission et il y
a quand même pas mal de fébrilité du
côté de la majorité pour savoir comment
va va se comporter à l'air c'est un peu
kitouou mais c'est vrai que
effectivement s'il arrivait à à éviter
entre guillemets un crash et une un 493
à la majorité il il serait un atout mais
il reste une personnalité très clivante
c'estàdire que et notamment au sein de
la majorité c'est qu'on a bien vu qu'au
moment du du du du remanement
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas voulu non plus
aller dans cette direction là parce que
sur encore la jambe gauche de cette
majorité c'était un une fin de recevoir
c'est une personnalité qui reste dans
ses positionnement même s'il joue une
carte sociale proche proche des Français
qui qui heurte par par ses prise de
position trop droitière une partie de de
la majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui
et et àar ellisabeth borne elle est très
effacée sur ce texte qui est vraiment
porté par par Gérald daranin est-ce que
ça explique aussi ces mauvais chiffres
heran ou pas pour Elisabeth bne non en
réalité je je pense que Elisabeth borne
elle a vraiment cette difficulté
d'équilibre au sein de sa major de
ménager et la jambe gauche et la jambe
droite de l'équipe gouvernementale c'est
plus des des initiatives personnelles
qui peuvent la décrédibiliser en tant
que chef de gouvernement on parlait du
rassemblement de Gérald haranin à à la
rentrée ça fait plus partie de ces
choses après que des des projets
spécifiques soi portés par des ministres
et des ministres emblématiques là le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour
l'immigration c'est ça relève de de des
choses assez classiques on va terminer
là aussi comme tous les mois par le B
palmarès des personnalités la côte
d'adhésion Audrey et Gabriel Atal a
toujours V pou oui le ministre de
l'Éducation encore lui arrive en 2e
position du palmarès de l'adhésion plus
de points par rapport au mois dernier
mais plus 17 points depuis le mois de
juin pour le reste le classement reste
le même qu'il y a un mois Édouard
Philippe est toujours en tête Marine Le
Pen 3e devant Jordan bardellaa et Bruno
Le Maire a noté que dans cette tête de
classement tout le monde progresse de 2
à 4 point et creuse l'écart avec le
reste des personnalités politiques
notamment avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui s
roule depuis quelques mois il est en 17e
position de la côe d'adhésion alors
qu'il était 6e avant l'été ou et on va
revenir sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon Erwan les
5 premiers ça bouge pas non ça ça bouge
pas alors faut faut toujours signaler
quand même cette spécificité du du
paysage politique français maintenant
dans l'opinion où on a deux
personnalités Jordan Bardella et surtout
Marine Le Pen qui viennent d'un parti
quand même à l'extrême de leschiquier
politique qui sont parmi les
personnalités les plus appréciées des
des Français c'est que c'est c'est ça ça
exprime aussi ce classement la
normalisation du rassemblement national
dans dans l'opinion mais c'est vrai que
c'est assez stable avec Édouard Philippe
qui arrive à un niveau très on parlait
tout à l'heure des 35 % de code
d'adhésion d'Emmanuel Macron là on voit
bien qu'on a deux autres chefs de parti
qui sont à des niveaux supérieurs ça ça
raconte des choses aussi sur les
équilibres politiques nationaux plus
pardon plus qu points pour Édouard
Philippe depuis le mois dernier oui oui
il continue de de de progresser
ilengrange dans dans la période sachant
que sur le conflit israélo-palestinien
on l'a vu aux affaires on l' vu au
Congrès des maire aussi la la semaine
dernière c'estàdire que il est présent
et continue à engranger des soutiens et
ces cinq premiers alors ils illustrent
la normalisation du RN la Diwan est-ce
qu'ils illustrent aussi le match entre
la majorité et le rassemblement national
dans les CIN premiers il y a que de la
majorité et du Aren oui tout à fait ben
on a bien vu donc que le le le le
conflit enfin l'attaque du Hamas contre
Israël a été un point un peu de de
rupture pour pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon he
qui qui déjà n'avait pas engrangé les
bénéfices on en a souvent parlé de la
réforme des retraites où pourtant la
nupes et la France insoumise av était en
en tête voilà de la contestation qui
était soutenue par une majorité des
Français mais ça ne se voyait pas en
tout cas dans les sondages et dans
l'adhésion à cette méthode voilà mais
c'est vrai que ça sa sa prise de
position qui a consista à ne pas
qualifier le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste a vraiment se met à la fois
dans son parti dans l'opinion politique
on l'a vu dans de nombreux sondages un
un voilà un rejet encore plus fort et ça
on le voit bien et à contrario Marine Le
Pen a mené une stratégie voilà qui a
consisté à à manifester un soutien
inconditionnel à Israël on l'a vu les
premiers jours à la marche de soutien au
au Trocadero où sa présence a déjà enfin
la présence en tout cas de Jordan
madellaa a un peu horté voilà les gens
mais en tout cas été accepté reçu donc
c'est vrai que par rapport au
positionnement à la ligne antisémite de
son de son père ça a vraiment marqué une
rupture elle sait qu'elle n'a jamais
désavoué ou officiellement voilà rejeté
mais elle n'a pas un logiciel antisémite
dans sa façon de de de voilà de de
diriger son son parti et ça ça a marqué
voilà une étape dans cette
dédiabolisation et on a vu ensuite cette
cette c'est cette façon de de prendre à
cour hein tous les partis et la majorité
pour la marche contre l'antisémitisme où
chacun a dû se positionner par rapport à
sa présence dans cette marche et là
encore ça a été une autre une autre
étape donc oui on a bien vu la majorité
expliquant qu'ils allaient être présents
ou pas et elle continue de jouer cette
partition sur l'hommage aux victimes
mettant voilà la position de Macron qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas participé enfin elle
mène un peu le le jeu et le débat sur ce
sur ce thème- là et donc c'est c'est
vrai que on voit elle continue
d'engranger en tout cas ça le rejet
reste important mais c'est vrai qu'il
est beaucoup moins important qu'avant il
il a perdu 15 points entre 2017 et 2022
entre les deux séquence présidentielle
alors que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait le
mouvement inverse sur le sur le rejet
c'est vrai que la radicalité aujourd'hui
en dans la politique nationale est
beaucoup plus porté par la France
insoumise qu'elle ne l'est par le
rassemblement national qui incarne
beaucoup plus un RN notabilisé normalisé
et et sans tumulte à à contre au
contraire de de la France insoumiso
Mélenchon c'est lui le grand perdant de
ces derniers mois sur ce cette palmarès
des personnalités ran oui c'est vrai que
c'est c'est c'est c'est vraiment assez
emblématique de ce qu'on observe pour
l'anupes depuis un an c'estàdire que au
moment de la fondation de de laanupes
pour les législatives de 2022 Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la France insoumise sont le
centre de gravité légitime et naturel de
la gauche aujourd'hui suite à de
nombreuses prises de position finalement
ils se sont radicalisés à l'intérieur de
laanupes à avec un positionnement
politique qui les place nettement à la
gauche de laanupes du coup ils ont perdu
en légitimité sur ce plan-là je Mélan il
a perdu 20 points de code d'adhésion
auprès des sympathisants de la gauche
c'estàdire que sa code d'adhésion reste
très élevée chez les sympathisants LFI
mais elle a périclité chez les
sympathisants écologistes et du Parti
socialiste et c'est c'est assez étonnant
parce qu' il y a ce côté un peu Pyroman
chez Jean-Luc Mélanchon qu'on avait déjà
observé en 2018 il avait une image très
consensuelle en 2017 à la présidentielle
en 2018 on a la République c'est moi les
perquisitions au siège de LFI et il
radicalise son image pour la
reconsensualiser à l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 et que heureux 1
an après alors après des séquences
politiques entre les les retraites et le
conflit israëlo-palestinien mais du coup
une image qui se radicalise et c'est
vrai que on a l'impression d'un éternel
recommencement mais avec en tout cas la
franceouise qui est dans une posture
très radicale au sein de l'anupes et on
va revoir la la dernière infographie sur
la gauche parce que c'est vrai que dans
ce baromètre quasiment toutes les
personnalités politiques augmentent sauf
des personnalités de gauche Fabien
Roussel Bernard casneuve Olivier fort
est-ce que ça veut dire clair que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il entraîne un peu
tout le reste de la gauche dans sa chute
bah il voudrait que la responsabilité de
la fin officielle et définitive de
l'anip ne soit pas lacienne donc on sait
on a vu on on a déjà commenté ici cette
espèce de de de de de flottement enfin
voilà où chacun veut mettre un moratoire
essayer de trouver parce que chacun a la
conviction que l'Union permettra à la
gauche d'émerger dans les prochaines an
électoral y compris y compris pour la
présidentielle mais effectivement
aujourd'hui il y a a y a une impasse
totale lié à ce discours extrêmement
radical qui est aussi critiqué en
interne on en parle souvent il y a des
personnalités notamment comme François
Ruffin qui lui d'ailleurs je sais pas si
ça se vérifier encore mais montait plut
tôt et et n'avait pas la même
trajectoire que les autres parce que
précisément il était dans un refus de
cette antagonisation permanente en se
disant ça ça ça ça nous dessert et il
faut qu'on trouve un autre une autre
façon d'avancer plus constructive donc
effectiv ement aujourd'hui c'est c'est
peu audible ça ne fait pas l'opinion ça
ne fait pas les débats ça ne fait pas
les lois on voit bien que le centre de
gravité du voilà de de la politique du
discours est clairement plus à droite
merci pour ce barromètre Menel au mois
prochain du coup on verra sur quoi eran
on va terminer avec la revie de presse
régionale comme tous les
[Musique]
jours etud on commence cette revue de
presse par une bonne nouvelle tan enfin
libre titre ni matin le garçon de 12 ans
et demi fait partie des trois otages
français libérés hier par le Hamas et
remis à Israël après 53 jours de
captivité il avait été enlevé avec son
père le 7 octobre après l'attaque contre
leur kibuts à 2 km de la bande de Gaza
pour sa grand-mère Joceline une noise de
76 ans c'est le soulagement elle ne
savait pas avant de voir les images s'il
était mort ou vivant le petit va
retrouver sa mère et ses deux sœurs
relogées en Israël et reste cependant
une inconnue
son père dont la famille n'a aucune
nouvelle Ori l'actualité ce sont aussi
les suites dans l'affaire du meurtre du
jeune Thomas à crpul l'onde de choc n'en
finit plus de se propager depuis une
dizaine de jours titre Le Courrier
Picard la mort du jeune Thomas à crépul
suivi ce weekend de manifestations
violente de la mouvance identitaire sont
le symbole d'une France à cran selon La
Dépêche du Midi et Olivier verérrand le
porte-parole du gouvernement qui était
en visite hier dans la Drome craint même
un basculement de la société sud-ouest
évoque des tensions identitaires qui se
crispent et fait même en page intérieure
le lien avec l'élection du leader
d'extrême droite gerdvilders aux
Pays-Bas en évoquant un repli
identitaire populiste qui fait Tach
d'huile en Europe ouais Géral armanin
qui a réagi ce matin je ne laisserai
aucune milice d'extrême droite ou autre
faire la loi a dit le ministre de
l'Intérieur il va proposer la
dissolution de trois groupuscules
d'extrême droite on va parler d'un
procès très attendu qui commence
aujourd'hui oui le nouve un nouveau
procès pour Monique Olivier la veu de
Michel Fourniret devant les assises
aujourd'hui ça fait la une du Dauphiné
Libéré de l'ardenis et de l'Union
Monique Olivier qui devrait livrer ses
dernière vérité on l'espère en tout cas
à 75 ans est juger pour son rôle dans
l'enlèvement de trois jeunes filles dont
Estelle Mousin disparu il y a 20 ans
Michel Fourniret avait avoué avant sa
mort être son meurtrier mais le corps de
la fillette n'avait jamais été retrouvé
ce procès de Monique Olivier est donc
très attendu par les proches d''estell
nousin puis j'en profite avant de finir
pour vous montrer une une celle du Pr
qui rend hommage à Gérard colon ancien
maire de Lyon sénateur et ministre de
l'Intérieur décédé samedi dernier les
Lyonnais se succèdent pour lui rendre
hommage et puis cette fois c'est
vraiment la fin j'essaie de terminer par
une note un peu plus positive ça se
passe en Corse la farine de châtaigne
Appellation d'Origine protégé fait sa
résurrection c'est bon signe pour les
personnes qui sont intolérantes puisque
c'est une farine sans gluten voilà ça on
termine par une bonne nouvelle merci
Audrey on a vu quelquesun des journaux
du groupe ébrra on va en voir une autre
a clair celle du républicain Laurin
étudiant angoisse de l'assiette vide
c'est à la de votre journal merci
beaucoup claire Planchard merci à l on
se retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau baromètre merci Audrey merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 18h Thomas public et nous
on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée